EDUARDO SILVA: My
name is Eduardo Silva.
And the name of our
organization is Monkey Project.
Our organization just
focuses on web technology
to create a good communication
improving resource and trying
to optimize as much as possible.
This year, our project got
four slots for students.
And they were working
in different areas,
which was not related.
One of them was working
on proxy reverse staff.
Another one was working
on creating interfaces
to connect to databases.
And another one to create SSL
interface and different futures
for the whole technology,
which runs on HTTP.
In the future, I would like
that Monkey Project sees more
than technical futures.
I would like to see a summit
between the volunteers, people
working on GSOC and,
obviously, the core
contributers to try to create
some synergy between us.
Our organization,
Monkey Project,
has been participating
on GSOC on 2012
and this the present year.
And personally, I have
been the organization admin
for this project in
conjunction, obviously,
with the core team
of the project.
It's a big community.
We are always open to
receive new volunteers.
And at the beginning, we don't
care about technical skills,
because the project was born
because we were rejected
to participate in
something similar.
And we did not have the skills.
So it was like,
you don't know C.
You cannot participate on this.
So we don't reject
because of skills.
The success key to join our
project is to be motivated.
And I think that the best thing
that we look on the students
is that they must be motivated
to contribute on this.
If they're motivated,
they are going to learn.
They are going to try.
They're going to ask.
We don't care if some person
does have many programming
skills.
If he's not motivated, he's
not going to do a good job.
Part of GSOC, for me, it has
been a very important phase
on my life, because I was a GSOC
student before in 2006 and '07.
And I said, this was awesome.
I was running this open-source
project on that moment.
And we say as developers, A,
we need to move this forward.
We can engage more people.
We can talk about this.
We can motivate people.
And after three
tries, we did it.
And we continued working on it.
So personally,
the best reward is
about to see students
giving the best of them
and trying to learn things that
are not common in our project.
For example, they need
to lead with networking,
with sockets, Linux performance.
And they're not common staff.
So I think this is a
very special market
for this project.
I feel very happy to
see them moving forward
on this direction.